good afternoon thank you for joining us
here welcome to national spy museum my
name is Vince Houghton on the museum's
of storing in curator and we have an
extra special treat today this is not an
event that even existed about a week ago
we were able to put this together very
quickly and we appreciate you all coming
out we couldn't miss the opportunity to
have this man Jack Barsky sit in front
of you today
yes go do it you're on your own so
methods will take care you if you don't
know his background we're going to talk
about its aim is to give you a brief
introduction this is a life that is a
probable as it comes we talk a lot here
in the museum about how spy pop culture
is not necessarily true in many ways
about how it over exaggerated what
espionage actually is here we're going
to see a true spy story that really got
its beginning in a very humble backwater
so I can use that word of East Germany
but turn into a downright fascinating
story about a man recruited by the KGB
to infiltrate the United States and then
spent 10 years actively spying for the
Soviets he resigned and I joked earlier
that I'm not sure you can actually do
that from the KGB but then embarked on a
very successful second career in
information management when he was
finally discovered by the FBI in the
1990s he had wealth of information and
give them in return they let him become
a real US citizen and now he's as
patriotic as you and I living as an
American and taking advantage of all the
things that he couldn't have behind the
Iron Curtain as a normal life here in
the United States what interesting thing
is the longest surviving known member of
the KGB illegals program that operated
during the Cold War
so you've seen shows like the Americans
you know Philip and Elizabeth Jennings
and main cars those were Soviet illegals
Jack is the longest surviving member and
operated for many many years here inside
the United States he's also the author
of the book deep undercover my stupid
life entangled allegiances as a KGB spy
in America which will have in the back
and if you stay a little bit to sign
them I'll be happy to do that
so welcome jack thank you taking the
time to talk this here Universal Spy
Museum think you can can I say something
absolutely the longest surviving member
of really is important to me I'm still
very competitive
the the person who had the record was
also known as Colonel Abel his real name
was Eddie Fisher actually and he was
featured in the bridge of spies he he
managed to stay here undetected for
eight years I actually managed put ten
and another nine until the FBI finally
found me but I have two ten years I did
that resignation thing I would say the
longest surviving is probably the key
word memory you know that also I want to
start by talking about luck and I think
this luck plays such a key role in your
story both good and bad starting with
where you were born so a lot of people
have conversations about God we're so
lucky to be born in a knighted state so
I can't imagine how it would be being
born in the third world we're not having
this game kind of creature comforts we
have here well you were born in East
Germany during the beginning of the Cold
War when there really wasn't a lot of
creature comforts it wasn't just the
East Germany was behind during the
Second World War and right after the
Soviets had stripped essentially most of
what mattered inside East Germany that
was the world you were born into that's
right uh as far east as you could go in
Germany without being in Poland I
consider myself sort of as as a result
of world war two because my parents met
because there was towards the end of the
war that people would flee the oncoming
Russian army and they would go West
didn't get very far but they wound up in
the same space and that's how I got
created in 1949 so without that war I
wouldn't be here and then and without
and I wound up in
in the soviet-occupied part of Germany
which then became the German Democratic
Republic a communist has satellite to
the Soviet Union so without communism I
wouldn't have signed up with the KGB and
without that I wouldn't be here and
without that I wouldn't be an American
citizen today so this is all I told a
bit bizarre but there's a lot more to my
story that you know you shake your head
and that really happened I think what
was interesting is without the war even
more so you wouldn't have been in this
position because many people here may
not understand in East Germany during
that time the war was still very fresh
and Hitler was still very fresh inviting
fascism installing in the communists in
the Soviets leading the fight in
basically doing all the heavy lifting
against the Soviet against the Germans
during the war how did that shape your
your youth in your hood well the Soviet
Union as some of you may know bore the
heaviest brunt and in the fight against
Hitler and so we East Germany became on
you know I came on the Soviet influence
and you know we were very glad that we
were we were an anti-fascist type nation
and I tell people this is one of them
one of the biggest mistakes I think the
United States made or the CIA or whoever
made that decision was to co-opt Nazi
military intelligence also known as the
Kalin organization Reinhard Calvin was
the head of that organization that that
we know was co-opted by the CIA and it
eventually became the Bundestag
experiences is the the West German
intelligence agencies so that they were
all Nazis and and we were on the other
side because the the only political
force that actively fought the Nazis in
the streets before they took power or
the Communists so we were the good guys
they were the bad guys
I believe that that that juxtaposition
allowed for
years and years and years of propaganda
in addition to some ex-nazis becoming
you know even chanted it was a
chancellor in the West Germany who
called GERD kissing on who was a man I
had been a member of the Nazi Party so
you know I was ideologically a fully
convinced that we were on the right side
of history and I and that was the major
reason I jumped in and said yes when the
KGB knocked on the door it's one thing
to learn basic tradecraft and in skill
set that can be taught it's another
thing to have a psychological makeup to
be an effective undercover spy inside
the United States what of your
upbringing and your intelligence and
everything you learned until you were
recruited by the KGB made you the right
person for this kind of job well it was
a pretty tough life
we were poor we didn't know it though
but you know there was a lot of delayed
gratification involved there was a lot
of discipline you know my parents were
typical Germans and you know I had to be
followed their rules to a tee and I
learned early on that nobody really
cared about me so I could take care of
myself there's a bunch of examples in
the book about that you know there's a
mental toughness and my mother kicked me
out of the house early you know ITC and
that was she meant well she sent me to a
boarding school when I was 14 so I
learned how to say goodbye and then I
went to university there was so far away
that I never had a chance to go home
only during some of the recess so so
there were there were a lot of things
that were in combination made me a good
from a psychology aspect a good
candidate to say goodbye to everything
that I knew and everybody I knew and
then start over someplace else I can
still do it today I just moved by my
family from upstate New York to Atlanta
and
I don't it didn't bother me one bit and
my curls are a little bit that's my
girls my wife and my daughter they have
their home sakes and I'm not lots of
training to get out of acid today if you
wanted to join the CIA you go online to
CIA gov and apply there the KGB had a
different way of doing things but when
they were recruited you they didn't just
say come work for us what's interesting
and you really lay this out in the book
well if anyone's interested in this
process it's done here such a great way
they really slow played your recruitment
they didn't come right out and say
jacker
or Ulbricht we want you to join the KGB
they took their time to make sure you
were the right fit you talk a little bit
about your recruitment process yeah it
was a mutual feeling out initially it
was just you know the question was
asking would you be interested in
something like this and at that point I
was quite clear to me I could have said
no and when I said well let's take a
look and now they'd they needed to find
out for themselves whether they thought
I was the right material because you
know you from from from early on it was
clear that if I were to sign with them
so to speak it would be for undercover
work and you as Vince pointed out that
it requires a certain personality to be
able to do that so they learned about me
we met with I met with my handler for
once a week and we talked about
everything life issues and we became
pretty good friends he got to know me
very well and on top of it he gave me
little tasks and you try this you know
you know go do an investigation over
there find out what you know about this
particular object write a report and on
and on and on and I bet you he wrote a
report back to the center every time we
and on at my end it was he gradually
introduced me to the idea of what it
would be like to do this kind of work
took about a year and a half before they
popped the question
and when that question was popped it was
done by a very senior person in Berlin
and uh I had 24 hours to say yes or no
I could I could have said no at that
point still because you don't for this
kind of work you don't work with
somebody who you are encourage or force
into the service it needs to be a
volunteer when I ask you about your
first impressions uh during a training
mission to West Berlin that was your
first chance to see the the West that
had been just given to you through
propaganda and through other ideas what
what did you see when you went to West
Berlin how did that did that change your
ideology to change our opinion is
reinforced we've been told well first of
all I need to give folks a perspective
in those days we didn't have color TV
and I lived in an area where you
couldn't get West German TV at all we
were we called it the valley of the
clueless and so I had no idea what what
I would what I would find on the other
side of the wall and the first
impression I got was all mine there's a
lot of color in this world you know the
buildings had colored the people would
dress nicely in the East everything was
gray and brown so that was interesting
but it certainly didn't make a dent in
my ideology on the the other thing that
it was I was scared out of my mind I
thought you know I was running around
with the head witness we let us on my
forehead is saying KGB and every cop
that I saw his Oldman he wasn't talking
me know I survived it was
psychologically rather stressful because
this was enemy territory this was where
this was the folks that I was going to
fight in my soda way no we were joking
when we talked earlier that we were
going to have you come out with a German
accent just to kind of mess with the
audience a little bit be like goes
coming over why the Americans wouldn't
understand but clearly you don't have
one if anything you've got a Jersey or
in New York accent you didn't grow up
speaking English you learn English as a
second variant in tertiary language
let's talk about your English training
because many people this room have
probably taken a language in school I
took Spanish for the better part of a
decade and I only know the bad words but
I can pronounce it really really well
but learning English learning a second
language to be as deep undercover as you
were wasn't just about learning
vocabulary know is about learning nuance
and slang an accent you talked about how
how did that training work for you no no
you're doing that again you're asking
like three questions
[Laughter]
I took we had compulsory Russian in
school starting in sixth grade and I
studied Russian for six years and I
remembered next to nothing we also had
voluntary English we could either take
French way in which I took English and
that came very easily to me but I didn't
retain much when when I was in training
in Berlin I was supposed to be headed to
West Germany that was the normal way you
know to send a German to the other side
of Germany undercover that's really easy
but I also was told you know you need to
learn one other language so I picked
English and I started learning English
and as I told you before I'm pretty
competitive so and I worked hard so I
start and I learned and I learned and so
about a year and a half into my training
some visitor from Moscow came over and
asked me so how's your English says it
oh and I pulled out it a book I said I'm
reading this novel by the way I don't
need a dictionary even aw and it's in
okay why don't you make a tape and see
what you know what you sound like so I
made a tape sent it to Moscow and they
immediately flew me into Moscow and had
me interview with the
two ladies one was a professor of
English Russian at Moscow University
worked for the KGB obviously and the
other one was an American who had
emigrated with she married a Russian
most likely KGB and and they interviewed
me separately and to determine as to
whether I could I had the ability to
learn English as well enough to claim to
have been born in in the United States
and it was a tie the American said he
can and the the Russian professors will
not happen no way and you know here
wishful thinking comes in so when the
the the Commerce had made the decision
figured noon let's let's give it a shot
it's too tempting and so then I spent
two years in Moscow lining English with
my tutor was this American lady and then
and a couple who is well known in
amongst in circles such as folks who run
the spy museum and I and I threw myself
at that task and I really wanted to
succeed and it sort of worked out I know
I now speak English much better than I
speak to him and that's a fact
do you still do you still identify with
your German name with your German
background is that have you completely
left that behind or is there still
something in you that looks back at your
youth alone if I was that I went back to
Germany no since I became a citizen
three times and the those folks all
still call me by my german name or my
german nickname which I hate but it's
okay over there but I am certainly more
the American and there's I have proof
proof of that and I was driving with a
history professor the other day in
Atlanta in the car and I was talking
about Germany and the United States and
I used us and that
and we and they and she said you know I
caught you you constantly referring to
Germany as them so I am now you know
first-generation immigrant and the
immigration process was a little odd but
[Laughter]
American and you know I've long since
stopped thinking in German but one thing
is interesting I read this in a book one
day and it's still true I counted German
hmm just a weird question you ever dream
in German not anymore
okay no no actually after about a year
in the u.s. I proudly reported back to
the to the center that I'm now dreaming
in English cuz I remember that very well
let me ask you who was Jack Barsky or
what is her name come from it was stolen
and that was standard operating
procedure this is how the the Soviets
manufactured false IDs they would look
for in for records of individuals who
passed away at a young age in my case
there's a there's a there's a cemetery
not too far on it some place in Maryland
I forgot the town where there's a
gravestone that says Jack Barsky born in
1944 passed away in 1954 I believe it
was ten years old and one of the
resident agents who probably worked at
the Embassy here found that and got the
birth certificate pretending to be the
father of a young boy and then it was
sent to Moscow and I took that with me
when I came to the United States and
then used this to build an ID and had
identity with genuine American document
it wasn't just about building a name
there's a whole backstory I'll show here
- I mean cover and ID is just one thing
but the KGB helped you to create an
entire person behind Jack bars sure yeah
you know according to to that birth
certificate and I was born in 44 so that
made me already in my mid in my early
thirties when I came here it made me
five years older than I really am i was
born 49 so we constructed a cover story
that started out with that birth
certificate and then there was an agent
in new york who went around the city and
took pictures of places where i could
have lived well and where I went to
school you know middle school elementary
school high school and even found
information about a factory that I could
have worked at that was a factory that
downtown Manhattan that manufactured
chemicals and that had burned down so
there was no more record of that Factory
so we we we covered a period of my life
in the u.s. having worked in that
Factory and then we came up with the
idea that you know that I dropped out of
high school since I didn't have a high
school diploma and my mother passed away
during that time and then I just moved
up and went to work on a farm in upstate
New York
for several years - so I dropped out of
society and then I came back to New York
to give it another try and so that's
when my real life started kicking and I
never really used any of that legend but
it was necessary to have just in case it
it gave you the certainty that people
ask you questions that you have answered
it the KGB gave you extensive training
as we've already talked about but there
are only certain amount of things that
they can know some nuances some cultural
differences that you kind of had to
learn the hard way - stories I want you
to kind of bring up one is about a beer
bottle in Canada and one is about a
passport in Chicago can you give those
stories very quickly so you can
understand how the KGB couldn't possibly
prepare you for
every circumstance no that's and you
know this is it no matter how much you
think about what could happen there's
things that you're not prepared for so
here's some weird issues where I didn't
have the cultural training to be an
American right away that took a while to
assimilate and so my I took a test trip
to Canada for three months to learn to
live in you know to speak the language
and you know be as close to the United
States as possible as she can be without
being in it first night I went to dinner
and restaurant and I got a bottle of
beer and I'm looking around and there's
no bottle opener so I asked the waiter
husband and I was I was proud of the
fact that I knew the English word for
bottle opener and I said can can I have
a bottle opener he looked at me like hmm
I said you know I need to open this
thing and he with a smirk on his face he
took it and twisted the cap off while we
didn't have twist-off caps in East
Germany or Russia for that matter so
that was that was just like weird wasn't
it and and I and I and I traveled with a
West German passport so they did have
twist-off so that's one I think the
other one is that it's it's only funny
in hindsight you know so when when when
I entered the United States to O'Hare
Airport in Chicago I was traveling I was
using a
a Canadian passport and I hadn't sewn
into a piece of luggage I had I had this
birth certificate of the jack Barsky so
when I went to a hotel and that's why I
killed off the Canadian and brought to
life they came Jack Barsky kept that
killing was much harder than expected
how do you destroy a passport not that
easy they're flame-retardant so I tried
to burn you couldn't even burn the paper
and never mind never mind the plastic
outside the picture and you know it
started smelling it doesn't work that
way and you know you start sweating you
know you're making it and you're making
a stink and I would tell them no
hopefully nobody will you know stop by
and ask what's going on fire alarm
didn't go off so eventually I took a
pair of scissors and just cut it into
small pieces and flushed it down the
toilet so that was not part of the
curriculum how did this toy a passport
there are also some this book is by the
way there's hillarious moments where
I've had to put the book down laughing
another one was or I put myself in your
shoes and I imagined I've I haven't been
an undergrad in a long time but you got
the pleasure for life over the word you
were going to be a chemistry professor
yes before you were brought into the KGB
right but because he didn't have a
degree in the United States even a high
school degree nothing you had to go be a
freshman at City College in New York and
take freshman classes that you just
actually teach as a professor like
chemistry 101 and calculus one yeah
obviously did pretty well almost too
well I thought actually at a much higher
level than anything that I was exposed
to at the undergraduate level like
chemistry 101 was like Mickey Mouse
stuff and nai calculus one two and three
I taught at a more advanced level then
that stuff so it
these subjects were all a breeze now I
got to tell you I did not I did not cut
corners I didn't for a foreign language
I did not take German and I did not take
Spanish which I had acquired on my own
during the first couple years here I
took I took French but anyway there was
a was an outcome that was unplanned and
had something to do with still being
ignorant about certain aspects of
society
I aced the whole program so now I'm a
valedictorian says it hey coke they
called me into the offices says so okay
we would like to you know you need to
give a speech I just what no yes yes you
have to you have the best GPA and that's
it I said well but I don't really
deserve it on you know let some younger
kids do this no no no no no and oh by
the way if you feel uncomfortable you
can write it and let somebody else read
it well that I couldn't accept so here
is the undercover KGB agent who's giving
a valedictory at a United States College
and in New York City in New York City
and nobody ever noticed that this was a
little bit odd you know in terms of my
age in terms of the fact that I actually
went through the program in three years
I mean it was nobody was alert to that
there's there's something kind of
unusual about this guy let's just video
another great story from this time that
shows how good you were was you had you
befriended a young man from Hong Kong
who you taught English to yeah which is
fantastic the fact that you he asked
you'd like your English you know you're
a native speaker can you write we had to
be a native speaker well I noticed
something would he wasn't in a political
science class
he was sitting next to me and he
underlined a lot of this book and I fit
and I told him hey listen you got so
much yellow here that's useless I mean
your underlying almost the entire book
and then he said well these are
words I don't understand the kid had
just come from from China and he was
learning English while he was in college
so I took him under my wings and I said
you know I applied what I learned in in
Moscow I bought a book phonetics book
and we did phonetics exercises together
and I helped him learn English and he
actually wind up he had to write an
essay or a couple of essays for his
application to law school at Columbia
and one of them he wrote about me how
you know how this nice American help
them learn English yes yeah he is now a
very wealthy very successful attorney in
New York well now you have multiple
degrees from different continents and
you go down to your career which is
working in information management
platform
MetLife the big bad nasty capitalist Pig
dog insurance company right not exactly
what you expected when you got there
yeah this is not an exaggeration there
were the insurance companies for some
reason were singled out as the epitome
of evil and capitalism so and when I
started working at MetLife they were all
still Mutual and they were very
paternalistic in other words you know
they they compact the unspoken audio I'd
sometimes I directly spoken compact was
if you start with us you're going to
retire with us you're going to work here
until retirement you're going to get a
gold watch and and you're going to get a
pension oh wow it felt like I'm back
home you know it was just instead of
instead of the the insurance company
back home it was the state it was the
government that told you where to go and
then they would take care of you and you
know same kind of feeling and it felt
really good you know because I was still
I was so used to you know cradle to
grave and this was close enough and and
there weren't any evil people and the
bosses were pretty nice and they paid us
well and we got free lunch pretty good
that
started at that point I started
softening my attitude towards capitalism
and towards the United States up until
that point I had no I had no point of
reference because as a bike messenger
you know I wasn't really a member of a
fully functioning member of society and
as a student I wouldn't have known
either so after 10 years working in the
United States for KGB you actually got
the emergency signal to leave but which
is people may have seen this in a TV
short movie it sounds great out of that
where you got the radio signal but also
a signal on a secret signal on the
street saying drop everything and go now
that's real and that was one one of the
more poignant moments in my life I had
to tell the KGB in detail how I went
from my apartment to work or at least to
the subway and actually also what trains
I took but they knew the footpath that I
used to get to the subway station and
there was a spot that I described to
them where they could put signals and
the emergency signal was a red dot and
it wasn't the size was about fist size
and one day I walked to the subway and I
see that dot and now we're being filmed
I can't say the S word but that's what
came into my head because then that
meant it was it was an order get out of
here no questions asked no I had some
emergency documents that were hidden in
a parking in Manhattan actually it was
in the Bronx I was supposed to retrieve
them and then make a beeline to Canada
get in contact with the Toronto would
have been a trade and trade delegation
delegation or something like that and
which then would and they would then
expert rate me to go back to Moscow but
I didn't do what that Dodd ordered me to
do why not why did you stay well
unbeknownst to the folks in Moscow
I had a girl daughter here too 18 months
old and I had bonded with her like you
know your father's and his audience you
you know what I'm talking about
you know if you this was the first child
that I was with and watching her grow up
and it was the first instant that I
experienced unconditional love that
means you don't want anything and if you
love him no matter what and you don't
want anything in return and it broke my
heart thinking that I might not be able
to ever see her again if I go back and
even more so I was afraid that she might
not have a good life growing up without
my support it was a tough decision to
make but I did make it eventually and I
stayed back so this is a 1988 so it
you're 40 years old and you had talked
about the fact that for those 40 years
you had never had that kind of an
attachment that you couldn't just grow
it up and walk away from as I was able
to walk away from from everybody and
that includes rather shamefully from my
German spouse so the KGB doesn't kind of
just let people walk away especially in
stay in the United States how did you I
loved the story I mean it gets somewhat
disturbing at the same time but it
friends out how did you convince the KGB
to leave you alone okay so I had to
figure out I wanted to make sure that
they they wouldn't come after me or
possibly even do harm to my German
family so I was racking my brain what do
i do what do i do so eventually I needed
to tell them that I'm not following
orders so I wrote a Dear John letter and
it went something like dear comrades I
have to have to tell you that I decided
not to come back because I have
contracted AIDS and
the only place where I could get
treatment is this country and then I
added some supporting information and I
actually trace it back to somebody I got
the AIDS from and that worked I know
that they believed it
how do I know it because I also told
them to give my German wife the money
that was saved on my account and they
did and they told your German wife that
you had died of it yes they did yeah
this one and I know that because my son
who is now 33 years old we have been in
contact for the last five years so he he
told me all the story that what it was
like to be at the other end your story
shifts pretty dramatically when the SBI
shows up at your door let's take a
little before that you know how did the
FBI find out about you in the first
place yeah so as another dramatic moment
Susan I didn't think there would be
another one because when you know what I
what my you know I when I wasn't it
clear and I pretty much thought after
about three months after I did that
resignation thing I thought everything
was okay it was just like sort of blend
in with American society and live out my
life as a middle-class individual with a
family my wife and I we bought a house
we had another child everything was just
very normal and I forgot all about my
past unbeknownst to me there was a
fellow busy copying notes in the KGB
archives and he smuggled them out in
small pieces of paper in his socks and
then transcribed them in his home and he
buried the stuff in the milk-can and
eventually at first year he approached
the CIA I I believe the CIA would the
American Embassy somebody in the
American Embassy and they didn't believe
him so he went to the to the
to the British and they got him out of
there it was just after the Soviet Union
came down but you know certainly they
wouldn't have let him out that easily so
he had a suitcase full of information
and one piece of the information was
Jack Barsky and saying illegal they
didn't have much more and that came to
the FBI and they started looking for
Jack Barsky now if this was Joe Smith
they wouldn't have found me but they're
not too many Jack barsky's and pretty
soon they they zeroed in on the fellow
who lived in a small village in
Pennsylvania and started investigating
me now they were very very careful
because there was at the time where
there were there were a couple of really
bad cases of espionage for moles in the
CIA and the FBI Robert Hansen FBI and
Aldrich Ames and the CIA so they were
concerned that I might be running
somebody in the government and so it
took him three four years to investigate
me very very carefully and supposedly at
that time I was I was the number one
case on their list of you know
counterintelligence cases and then one
day eventually they decided to go for
the kill so to speak and they said hello
that was a tense moment trust me well
the man who said hello is an FBI agent
or now retired FBI agent but named Joe
Reilly hmm you're really close friends
with him now yes I am actually I I spent
four days at his house while we I'm
gonna on a book tour and we went to the
Lehigh Valley and I spent some time you
know he hosted me and he's also the
Godfather to my last child my daughter
yeah we're really close and you know we
will close in many respects we we like
golf you we are politically sort of at
the same ideas and
you know obviously we also have a
similar background right except at one
point we were supposedly enemies whether
it chose to tell you that not you know
sometimes you associate yourself with a
group and become an enemy of another
group and in fact the individuals and
the other group could be just as good a
friend as the folks in your group it's
really strange I want to ask you a
couple broader cultural questions
because when we're trying to explain to
laypeople what you were coming here
today or like oh it's like like Philip
Jennings from the Americans except you
didn't kill a lot of people what do you
think of that what do you think of spy
fiction especially the Americans right
this is a very popular TV show based on
the illegals program do you just watch
it in shuffle or do you go okay there's
some truth to this the Americans is the
best show ever made because I'm going to
be on as an extra we didn't plan it at
all
may 9 10 I don't have a speaking part
but you know I I know they have a
relationship with the creator's and the
two core producers and they know what
they're doing they're doing
entertainment what they are doing really
well those is the the psychology of
undercover existence because anybody
who's seen this there's Philip
Brundtland constantly is drawn to the
American Way of life and he would tell
his wife so why don't we just stay here
you know it's we got a good life and she
is the one who's bringing back in mind
that that is quite realistic and the
other thing is you know it what got
really delicious when their daughter
becomes a question so but other than
that I am not aware of a realistic
depiction of the kind of work that I did
you talked about Philips Drive to become
more like in America let me ask you one
final question about all of us who grew
up in the United States have kind of
memories or nostalgia about Americana
we grew up watching baseball or we grew
up watching American
I can think of the American movies I saw
when I was seven years old that kind of
I still bring up today I can still quote
new scenes in lines from movies when I
was a kid how much or when if he did how
much did you embrace American culture
and what do you say now is the thing
that you embrace most is it are you a
Yankee fan or you are you somebody that
you should be but are you a Yankee fan
or or is there like you know you'll love
John Hughes movies you might not be the
right generation for that but it's a
part of Americana I
you really embrace I lack some of that
background but I I became a Yankees fan
when my son became a baseball fan so
every birthday from a certain age on I
would take him to a Yankees game and pay
a lot of money for good seats so I know
I understand baseball better than
football I've always played basketball
that part I like but let me tell you
what what I like the most about this
country and this will not be something
you might expect it's the Constitution
and the Bill of Rights if you go back
and read what what the Founding Fathers
meant to create it is awesome and
unfortunately where there's some forces
have work to get away from that that
sort of makes me sad yeah
we're going to open it up for questions
I'm sure you guys have some so if you
wait Amanda and Shawna both have
microphones so let them come to you so
first hand coming here on end has come
at the mic
oh so Peter is the executive director he
gets first questions like Natalie
attended it up he's handing it off well
thank you very thank you very much for
your presentation you haven't talked
about your collection epic what kind of
information did you collect and
transmitted back to the kgv well I was
in political intelligence quite honestly
I never personally handed any state
secrets handled any state secrets or
handed them over I was not in a position
to do so one of my tasks was to identify
individuals who might be candidates for
recruitment I never know never knew what
happened to those whether people were
being recruited successfully recruited
no idea I would occasionally not not
periodically send reports on you know
the mood of the reaction of the American
public to certain things and you know
elections you know because I was in in
the I was living in society rather than
looking at it from the outside so that
that's and then and then I did a few
like one-off tasks and towards the end
of my ten years they asked me to also
see if I can get my hands on some
technology when I I did send over a
collection of computer programs that's
pretty much it so you know people asked
me were you successful probably not very
much you did set up a dead drop you
might want to mention yeah so if you as
an illegal I could do things that others
the resident agents you know folks with
diplomatic cover couldn't do for
instance there was I don't know if there
still is but the Soviets were on the
restriction they couldn't travel outside
of 30 mile
or whatever it was outside of DC or New
York if they did they had to get
permission so and one time I was asked
to actually first they asked me if I was
going to do this if I was ready to do
this and I had no idea where they asked
me that question but it must have been
something extremely sensitive go find a
drop site someplace in New Hampshire and
when the time comes we may ask you to
collect something of a certain size it
was they told me this wasn't just a
little container it would have been a
suitcase or something I'm thinking that
was most likely to be sort of a
go-between between a mole in the United
States it could have been Hanson or Ames
and me to avoid those molds to have
direct contact with a resident agent so
you know that was some of the value that
day is quite to an undercover person I
also was supposed to observe a the
goings-on at a military object it's the
Naval Weapons Station in in Red Bank I
think it's still called Earle and that
does it was kind of odd because you know
I was supposed to go there woke a tional
I see if there's any movement that could
indicate preparation for war this to me
was more like believe nostalgic thinking
about how they operated World War two
and lastly and again this is in
hindsight to me that's backward thinking
the the value of an illegal that they
that they besides being able to move
around the country freely was if God
forbid relations were really bad and all
diplomats got kicked out they would
still have somebody behind enemy lines
on yeah yep you can you can debate
whether that makes a lot of sense
particularly when missiles fly around
you know
there's no more front line anywhere Oh
in New York would not be a particularly
good place to be
you wouldn't be staying behind all that
much right
yeah sauna yeah somebody oh now Peter
okay go jack first of all thank you for
sharing your fascinating story with us I
think it performs an incredible service
I also think that you speaking as an
intelligence officer you may have been
more successful than you realize in
other words a number of people that you
spotted for recruitment yeah you're not
really sure what the follow-on was and
it's quite possible that they followed
up on you're on your own the people you
spotted on your story about the KGB
fellow burying the information that was
Victor Matt roken right yes and the CIA
did turn him away he had a trunk full of
secrets would you dare was a CIA well
the reason i understood that they turned
him away the officer at the time and i
know who it was i won't name him thought
that this was just historical you know
this was trash this was oh probably not
of interest if we didn't have much of a
career that he wasn't that they
disbelieved him and and i directed a
fellow he took his story to the british
and i understand there was a woman who
received him and he told her his story
and she said oh sit down wouldn't you
like some tea they realized the
importance of that trove of information
let me ask you one question i was struck
by the fact that when you first came i
think was when you first came to the
west you commented that you were struck
by all the colors yeah but what really
was the impact of the Western Way of
life because the quality of life it must
have had an extraordinary impact I
always felt that people who can't the
East the West
it would just impact on them so strongly
yeah the material material wealth was
overwhelming you know when my you know
the couple of trips to West Berlin I
didn't get to see much but when I when I
spend time and
in Canada Montreal particularly and
there's a there's a big store department
store that I spent hours in just like
being totally blown away by the rich
assortment of things you can buy and I
wanted some of that and already this was
the beginning of a dichotomy that we all
of us lived through and we coveted the
goods cut that came from a society
society that we wanted to destroy that's
something that we all buried we didn't
want to think about it right so it
didn't make a dent with regard to my
perception of capitalism versus
socialism because the rational
rationalization behind thinking was that
America and West Germany were rich
because they exploited the third world
they got older their wealth out of you
know South America and Africa and so
forth that's what we were taught taught
anyway Sean hi I'm Christopher from the
German spy museum app to smaller
questions the first one why do you think
it is that you were picked by the KGB
and not the firm I mean I'm being born
that that's far east in Germany you you
would have struck me as well as a
cannula for the study not for you thank
you for first and the second one is you
mentioned that that incident was the
beer in Canada and you also mention that
you you saw some some of these caps that
turned open in West Europe
well I've been living in Germany for 32
years and never saw one of them could
you maybe pass that information well
verify that I can I just told you guys
alike so I I didn't know that but that
interesting for many many I mean so as a
historian in the 50s and early 60s you
were basically had a lot of influx
the Marshall Plan of American butt butt
into West Germany
so maybe there were flies or another
what that's that's my story and I'm
sticking to it it's a mystery question
were you handed off to the KGB because
you were potentially so good what why
didn't this toss to keep you for them
Sloane well I'm not sure that even my
first contact was a Stasi person I
thought so but in hindsight the Stasi
and the KGB actually worked pretty well
walled off they they're after Spiga
which is a german news magazine did some
research and they were looking for
anything about me and the Stasi archives
there's no trace of it and I'm one of
the few Germans who doesn't have a
record in there so I'm guessing somehow
the the Russians got to me first and
then told the Stasi stay away from this
guy
I don't know what the mechanics were how
they could pick some people and the
Stasi got most of them Stanley got most
of them but you know they had a couple
of thousand agents in in West Germany
and so you wonder why the Russians
wanted to have somebody else in West
Germany but they'd they had me to go go
there first before put up here Alan not
that I know who you are know that comes
the Mike so my question has to do with
actually the the family dynamic of this
thing so agent Riley shows up at your
door says hey we're the FBI we've been
looking at you how does this reveal go
to your American family who I presume
didn't know about your history and what
sort of I guess building back that trust
like hey my dad is someone I had you
know Nestor didn't quite know or what
their backstory was well my wife
actually know and this was a one thing
that I told Vince that I don't remember
at all but I once told her
we had a we had an argument and I tried
to make clear to her what I risked to
stay back with her and and my daughter
Chelsea and that was at a time when the
FBI already had a bug in my kitchen so
they had my my statement on tape and
that backfired by the way because her
respond her reaction was oh my god then
I'm not legal either that's a little
backstory behind that she had married
you gets to stay in the country because
you are a US citizen Kapoor yes thank
you for pointing that out
and so he liked the book you have to put
down the last certain time for signing
all right I'm trying to catch your eyes
she was she was more legal at that point
than I was but but anyway my my kids
were reacting very positively I'd waited
with for both of them until they were 18
years old right when I told my daughter
I mean she cried because you know
there's how do you prove to a child how
much you love them and that was a big
one other than you know maybe throwing
yourself in front of a bus to save him
and and my son when when he heard the
story his eyes were bigger and bigger
because you know he knew me as a really
not working desk jockey in corporate
America he like I could never explain to
him what I did because I was a manager
at the time and he once told his his
friend and I overheard and my dad
doesn't do real work he just sits in the
office all day and all of a sudden that
the faceless bureaucrat became an
international spies at all dad I got a
right above Christmas
speaking of a book so please join me in
taking Jack Barsky for taking the time
to talk he is here today and he will be
making his way to the back you want to
have a book sign say hello thank you
again